uh we're going to turn to the tokyo
olympics and some controversy actually
before the games begin later this month
last week
american sprinter shakiri richardson was
suspended
for a month after testing positive for
chemical found in cannabis
she's acknowledged she smoked marijuana
to cope with the death of her mother
and she says she accepts the punishment
she will not be able to compete in the
100 meter
dash at the olympics this comes after
the international swimming federation
barred the use of certain swim caps
designed for use
by athletes of color that's led to
allegations that some
olympic rules are written in a way that
can lead to discrimination we're joined
now by
jamelle hill a contributor and writer
for the atlantic she is also host of
jemele hill
is unbothered on spotify good morning
jamelle always good to see you
i know that you recently tweeted about
the olympics and said this
is sending a quote message
to black women what message is that that
you think the olympics
is sending well thank you ladies for
having me but uh when you look at the
full scope of what we see happening at
the olympics simone biles is probably
the face
of this olympic games at least from an
american perspective
and then you have the controversy around
gwen berry
you fast forward to what happened with
shaqiri richardson
now you have this swim cap band that
obviously affects
athletes of color obviously is an
impedim impediment
to young black swimmers and so there is
something that is there and you wonder
about these old school attitudes and how
they have
always in many ways disproportionately
impacted
athletes of color but in particular
black people because that's who we're
talking about here
you know that the world anti-doping
agency has listed marijuana as a banned
substance we know too that it's been
legalized in nearly 20 states do you
think
that it's time to have a conversation
about
what gets banned when it comes to
something like this
even you know the president's press
secretary was asked about shakiri
richardson and they acknowledge she's a
phenomenal athlete
she has an inspiring story but obviously
she will not be competing and she's
one of the world's the world's fastest
woman and jamil it's not as you know a
performance-enhancing drug either
no unless you have a bag of doritos at
the finish line
but um what i what i would say
is that you have to look at why is this
rule in place and it seems to be more of
a perception issue
than actually going with what is the
science i mean the fact is in 40
countries there is some form
of legalized marijuana we know where the
attitudes are moving in the states
and so much like the professional
leagues in america the nfl the nba major
league baseball
there's a reason they've all relaxed
their standards it has been used as pain
management and talking about marijuana
it is used in terms of coping mentally
and there are many athletes that came
forward
after what happened with shakiri
richardson to say that it helps them
with their anxiety
and i think we would much rather this
alternative
than i don't know alcohol or any other
sort of form of
any other dangerous substance i mean
considering all this young lady has been
through
we need to be happy the only thing she
did was smoke weed yeah just because
it's a rule doesn't mean it's right and
maybe we all need to look at
look at the rules because many of them
seem to be very outdated
and seem to be hurting black women in
particular
uh yeah i mean i i think when we assess
generally what has been our drug policy
in this country we know what
disproportionately affects
i was thinking about that swim cap rule
i wasn't even aware of that
yeah can we talk about the fallout
that's going on over at espn right now a
year after the audio
surfaced of rachel nichols talking about
maria taylor can you can you can you
briefly tell us what that's about and
your thoughts on it you worked at espn
you know the shop very well
yeah yeah i worked there for 12 years i
know both of these women
um and they're both very good we should
say they're both very good at what they
do
yeah yes they're vote they're both very
good both um
very admired and uh professionally by a
lot of people in this business and
essentially
in a private conversation that was um
you know that a lot of people at espn
heard because
uh it was on a company server uh you
know rachel
said some very disparaging things about
you know maria and
there was an assignment that was
promised to her contractually
and that assignment was going to go to
maria and kind of all hell is broken
loose and
listen gail you've been in tv for a long
time we know that
what happens behind the scenes it's a
very competitive business
sometimes it does not bring out the best
in people and
i think here what needs to be addressed
is culturally
how these things happen like what is
allowed to persist in certain
workplaces and i think i'm disappointed
in the fact that
you know maria has this very high
profile job it's great to see a black
woman have a job like that
it just does not seem like the company's
support was there
the fact that they would promise this
assignment to rachel nichols
i mean this is maria's job like why
would you even do that to begin with
because the fine the person who hosts
nba countdown
usually does the finals so to me that's
some kind of indication
that the support for maria hasn't been
there from the beginning and that's a
problem
i took the comments more disparaging
against espn than i did to maria
well but here's the other thing that
this touches on i mean i think
black women especially black people in
the workplace
we get a little tired of somebody
insinuating that the reason that we have
a job
is because we're black yes that gets
very tiresome
and i i know that um you know especially
in this business especially in sports
where you don't see a lot of black women
in the role
that maria is in she hears that a
hundred times yes
and so to hear that from a colleague
another woman i can imagine that that
would be very harmful and hurtful for
her and it is tiresome you're right
jamal have you spoke to either of the
women
uh i have not i mean i listen uh marie
and i have a good relationship
and what i don't want to do is be one of
these people that's hitting her up
when it's a whole lot of mess out there
i'll wait till things quiet down and
i'll reach out to her
but some of the other women at the
company's company some of the other
black women
i have reached out to them because i
know when you see a story like that
um you begin to question your colleagues
the environment
i understand i want to read what espn
said in a statement it says a diverse
group of executives thoroughly and
fairly considered all the facts related
to the incident
and then addressed the situation
appropriately
again you work there you know the ins
and outs and i think it's unfortunate
and complicated
situation but a conversation that needs
to be had jamelle hill
we thank you for joining us complicated
is the word
there and unfortunate yeah thank you
angel tiresome
thank you right now let's take a look at
your